well kirsten asks that las vegas
conventions could soon be a thing of the
past for fully vaccinated attendees
that's all thanks to a new emergency
directive from the governor himself
which would allow convention organizers
to ask for proof of vaccination organa
breaks down what this means
i patronize a few different conventions
here art gallery curator tony carnivale
attends several trade shows in las vegas
but there's one thing he does not like
about covet-era conventions i don't want
to see masks now that wish could come
true governor steve sisilak has
announced an exception to the indoor
mask mandate for conventions it would
allow organizers to require proof of
vaccination at conventions with 4 000 or
more attendees and only those fully
vaccinated would be able to go maskless
the other option would be continuing the
current rules which do not ask for proof
of vaccination but require mass for
everyone carnavali tells me the
exception is something he can get behind
i'm just not a proponent of the mask and
it seems that right now the only
alternative is the vaccination george
anne bender frequently speaks at las
vegas convention she says one downside
of the exception is the potential
economic implications of banning
unvaccinated vendors it could impact you
know the city personally i'd prefer an
atura mast
but on the other hand
i would like to have every retailer who
needs to attend that show attend that
show while conventions contemplate next
steps carnivale has one goal i just wish
and hope that we can get through this
sooner than later orc omana 8 news now
well under the new exception at
convention operators have to come up
with a way of separating attendees who
are fully vaccinated and partially
vaccinated those who are partially
vaccinated would still have to wear
masks